hi everyone so I am Alistair I lead the
commerce team in Google Play and I'm
going to talk a bit about commerce in
general and subscriptions in particular
something that we're very very excited
about what is commerce what is our
vision so it's kind of a the sentence is
kind of a mouthful the way we think
about this is like plays this gigantic
gigantic digital marketplace over a
billion users out there like millions of
developers or millions of apps out there
that yourselves run assaults those
people in a marketplace is about
transactions about linking those buyers
linking those sellers making those
transactions happen that's what our team
is about our aim is to build like pull
the energy in that flywheel more buyers
equals more sellers more sellers equals
more buyers and so we when we wake up in
the morning we're thinking about
building energy in that ecosystem that's
what Commerce is about in Google Play we
love to have like strategic pillars or
tenets and these larissa cut briefly
touched on these the way the ways that
we think about the commerce platform so
number one is reach in that previous
slide we had the word ubiquitous and the
word global our business is both Android
is built on massive massive reach well
over a billion users out there we aim to
make it possible for every one of those
users to transact on Google Play and
it's only a little bit more about the
things that we do in that space the
second is conversion once you've built
an app or built Senecas an experience
that is causing the user to enter a
transaction flow our team makes sure
that the user comes at the end of that
transaction flow having made a purchase
so conversion is a huge huge deal we
have a whole team of people again when
they're brushing their teeth in the
morning they're thinking about how to
increase conversion in your apps we also
think about trust actually David who
leads the trust team is going to be
giving a talk on what equals Fair Play
later on today this ecosystem is built
on repeat transactions our users make
tens hundreds sometimes thousands of
transactions in the ecosystem this is
real money these are real experiences we
were like a retail platform we have to
build and maintain trust for our users
and so we focus hard on that and then
the last tenet is growth like we believe
that there are things that Google Play
can do to drive energy in this ecosystem
we can put the right offers in front of
the right users at the right times and
so we've got a growth team that's also
focusing on building that well
energy in that flywheel so we talked
about reach so we have huge huge huge
reach the stuff is hard so we have
transactions enabled in over 130
countries and we have lots and lots of
local forms of payment so credit cards
are great that's awesome but the fact of
the matter is that there's a huge number
of users out there who do not have
access to a credit card and we need to
make it possible for those users to
transact on our platform
I always talk to the team about some
farmer in rural Indonesia who doesn't
have access to a credit card he doesn't
even have a bank account how are we
going to make it possible for that
person to make a transaction on the
platform so one of the things we've done
is direct carrier billing or DCB at i/o
we announced that we've crossed over 100
carriers just a few months later where
to actually a bit over 115 carriers
around the world who have direct carrier
billing enabled what this means is that
a user who doesn't have that credit card
doesn't have access to traditional form
of payment can make transactions in your
apps this stuff is hard I'll be honest
with you like just recently I was having
my brain melted by the requirements for
direct carrier billing in Kuwait but
it's worth it because once we figured
that out and once we launched direct
carrier billing in Kuwait by a growth
suddenly took off conversion took off
everything to go in Kuwait so we have a
big team that wakes up and thinks about
this all the time when now we have more
than 600 million devices around the
world which have access direct to direct
carrier billing so you'll have access to
those to sell to those users
subscriptions so subscriptions is a huge
deal we think this is the next big
business model for in-app billing so
over the last few years we've seen
massive massive growth in the
subscriptions ecosystem and the fact of
the matter is this is a great way for
you to monetize your apps if you're
selling a service or ongoing access to
content it's much better to build it as
a recurring service than to sell at one
time and support it forever so we're
seeing a lot of adoption of the
subsequent subscriptions business model
many developers are getting bored and as
a result we're seeing like massive
growth we think this can easily continue
in the future this enormous growth so we
focus extremely extremely hard on
subscriptions we're seeing a lot of
developers getting on board many of you
in the room are subscriptions business
models and so we love working with you
as you can tell we're focusing on this
you'll see more and more developers on
the slide in years going forwards across
a million different business models so
again you can tell I love strategic
pillars the subscriptions team also has
strategic pillars and we're going to
talk about each of these in a little
more detail so the first is integration
we want to make it easy for developers
or sellers such as themselves to
integrate with our subscriptions
platform but we've made some good
progress we've got a long way to go
we'll talk about that we also want to
make sure that sign up really really
really works for you this is our
strongest area largely to do with that
reach and we'll talk about that more in
more detail subscriptions are the gift
that keeps on giving but only if you can
retain those subscribers so retention is
a huge huge deal for us the stuff is
tricky and we have a big team focused
entirely on driving retention and then
lastly running or managing a
subscriptions business is tough it's a
lot of data based information you need
to really be looking at your cohorts and
we want to make that easy for you as
well so I mentioned briefly integration
if you're a simple developer like or a
mobile first developers integrating with
our subscriptions platform is extremely
extremely easy it's like any other
in-app billing but we're aware that many
of you are like multi-platform you have
a very sophisticated order management
system behind what you're doing and so
sometimes integrating with us can be a
bit of a pain and so the integration
team is working on making that easier
building features for you to make it
easier for you to integrate with our
platform and to run your business on our
platform and we'll talk a bit about some
of the features that are coming up in
this space as well sign up this is the
big one sign up is a huge huge deal for
us this is the conversion team is
thinking about this and this is also
where the reach team comes into account
so the two things the one is do we have
access to a form of payment that the
user also has access to and that's where
the store carrier billing comes into
can't we have gift cards in over 30
countries we have PayPal in many
countries we have local forms of payment
in other countries so does the user have
access to a form of payment is a huge
deal otherwise they just cannot convert
in your experience and then the second
thing is we actually have a lot of
buyers got huge numbers of people who
have already added a form of payment to
the Google Play ecosystem who already
accustomed to walking through this
experience and those users also converts
at much much higher rate
so we see a lot of success in this place
and a good example of this is our
friends at CBS after integrating with
the Google Play subscriptions platform
there's a napkin version winds up
enormous ly they so far more users
entering on their platform as a result
of the reach and as a result of the
conversion there's a whole conversion
team in Google Play just making this
purchase flow work better and better and
better another another example is coffee
meets bagel
they started off using the subscriptions
business model and now 20% of their
revenue is on subscriptions so this is
another good example of success building
a subscriptions based business and using
the Google Play subscriptions platform
coming soon is a feature that many many
of you have been asking for this is a
good way to drive down the friction in
that signup flow so we already have free
trials but a lot of the time what you
actually want is a highly qualified user
so you don't want it to be entirely free
but you do want a very low price for
that first few 1/n subscription period
so introductory pricing is very very
very close to launching as being tested
at the moment and you'll be able to use
this to convert more people into
subscribers at a lower price and then
they'll automatically revert to the full
price after as many periods as you like
so retention this is a big big deal
ultimately you're providing the value to
the users you're building the motivation
the user wants to subscribe in order to
retain access to your service or to your
content so you're building that
motivation some of the time however
something goes wrong the users credit
card expires or the payment network is
done and we suffer what's called
involuntary churn this is bad this is
really bad we do not want this to happen
ever and so we have an entire team
focusing on involuntary churn we think
about all of June we want to partner
with you to prevent voluntary churn but
the thing that these guys are thinking
about when I see them in the morning is
involuntary churn and fighting
involuntary churn there are two main
things that you can do in the space so
the one is retries and so we've got a
retries team that's figuring out the
right ways to retry the charges now
because we have so many different forms
of payment in so many different
countries the regulations change the
rules change and frankly the
interactions with those payment forms of
Peyman change as well so this team is
figuring out exactly the right time to
retry a charge when to retry it how
often to retry it to get the highest
recovery rate possible through retries
and then the second thing that we do to
fight involuntary churn is we actually
reach out to the users sometimes the
retries just not going to work that form
of payment is broken and so we need to
reach out to the user until the user
listen there's been a problem we need
you to take some action and so very very
recently we actually launched push
notifications from the Play Store to
users to tell them that their
subscription is broken and that they
should come and take action and again
we've seen improvements so I'm very
excited about the progress we've made
but frankly this team keeps on coming up
with ideas they keep on eking out more
and more recoveries and so I think that
there's even more upside in the future
in the space so we're going to continue
focusing on it management ultimately we
want to make it easy for you to run your
subscriptions business we want to build
tools we have a lot of internal
analytics on the subscriptions products
and businesses and we want to start
surfacing those and so you should see
that coming very soon in the developer
console will be releasing additional
subscriptions focused reporting and
management tools so that was a very
brief overview as I say I'm going to be
around all day we have the engineering
lead and other product managers on the
subscriptions team here today look out
for them I can introduce you to them we
think about integration so we've got new
api's coming out all the time we want to
make it much easier to manage your
subscription skews and in particular we
know that it's difficult to manage the
pricing of these SKUs so we're working
very hard on things like price changes
and on dynamic pricing of subscription
products signup is a big deal for us
obviously we've got the the reach team
who just continually is working on new
forms of payment we've got some very
exciting forms of payment in Europe and
in India coming up we've got the DCB
team the direct carrier billing team
always working on this stuff we've got
free trials we've got local pricing
we've got very low prices in some
countries and coming extremely soon
we've got introductory pricing launching
so I encourage you to test that art on
retention we've got that retention team
honestly these guys are the guys I go
and see every morning we've got to drive
up the retention rates for all of you
then subscriptions become the gift that
keeps on giving we want to we have been
testing art promotion codes so you'll be
hearing for
Beadie managers about working with us on
subscription promotions we want to be
able to do that we have been working
with intelligent retries or some very
interesting work there
we've got grace periods which have been
shown to make a huge difference to
retention mostly because it gives us
more time to do those retries we've seen
huge improvements in grace period when
grace period is enabled and as I said
we've just launched push notifications
the very first version we're going to
iterate on this to drive the user to fix
more subscriptions and then finally
we've got teams working on the
management tools in particular those
churn metrics as you can tell I'm pretty
obsessed with churn so we've got a lot
of reporting in that space and we're
going to be releasing that in the
developer console coming soon as well
thank you
[Applause]